[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
the honeydew with ryan zickler
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back to the honeydew y'all we're
over here doing it in the night pants
studios i am ryan sickler ryan
sickler.com ryan sickler on all social
media want to make sure to tell you
ahead of time about some dates coming to
phoenix arizona september 16th through
the 18th phoenix house of comedy i'll be
there for a few nights come on out let's
have some fun this shit's about to be
over y'all um make sure you subscribe to
the youtube channel please uh don't just
watch hit that subscribe button it means
everything to us and uh if you got to
have more do then you can sign up on uh
for the patreon all right for five bucks
a month you get a honeydew with y'all
where i do the honeydew with all and you
get the honeydew this show audio and
video a day early now on mondays ad free
at no additional cost it's five bucks a
month you sign up for a year you get a
month free all right if you or someone
you know has that story that has to be
heard please submit it to
honeydewpodcast
gmail.com hopefully we get to do an
episode together alright you know i
record here uh at the santa monica music
center um
and if you or anyone you know needs
music lessons hit them up go do some
online classes they'll waive the
registration fee in the first class when
you sign up for a package if you use the
code honeydew all right just doing that
to help out they're helping me i'm
helping them it's all good thing now
oh i do want to say night pants nation
joggers
and night pants all fully restocked all
the joggers are tight got a back pocket
on them and [ __ ]
and they're tapered at the leg they're
dope um you know what we do here we
highlight the low lights these are the
stories behind the storytellers
uh and today
storyteller here for the first time very
excited to have him here ladies and
gentlemen please welcome andrew colin
welcome to the honeydew thank you i love
that you looked up for the battle yeah
yeah people always forget about it you
got it you can't forget the [ __ ] poor
people up there it's like thunderdome
man you can't forget them up there man
hey man what's going on hey look look at
you you're here you know
um thank you very much for being here
yeah man thank you for having me yeah
before we get into anything plug promote
everything you'd like uh just the
podcast so i co-host uh the nikki glazer
podcast uh she's a comedian she's okay
you know she's you might have heard of
her i think i have yeah yeah she was on
something you know yeah and uh and then
i have my own podcast
called puddles with andrew collin
and then uh yeah that's pretty much it
we're going out on the road i'm opening
for nikki on our theater tour come july
so if you go to her website i should
probably put the dates on my website too
yeah yeah i keep forgetting that i
actually have people that would probably
go to it you know you know when you're
like coming up i'm
you know and you kind of just start
getting some fans and you still don't
believe it's real and i don't know if
that ever goes away when people ask me
if i'm ryan sickler never do i think
they or if i'm always like this my do i
owe this person money like is this
somebody is this somebody from the 90s
that's back to have some words with me
are you going to take my right i never
think that shit's about my comedy
no you're rising that [ __ ] depends man
who sent you
who sent you no i feel that dude i mean
i mean when i i had uh this one dude uh
this is before i did comedy when i did
real estate and uh i lost it so i made a
lot of money i'm like jumping in but i
lost everything and uh my house
i like lost my house i stopped paying
the mortgage and so this guy
the bank like you know sent the guy out
after me you know i forget what it's
called whatever when you go bankrupt and
every morning he'd show up at my house
knocking on the door like hey you know
you're trying to give me the papers or
whatever and i was i'd go hide in the
bathroom
and i would just hide and i'd say
my excuse was hey i'm in the shower like
that's what i was going to tell i got
ibs man i got ibf so so i keep my crown
just acting up
so every day i'm hiding in the bathroom
he's like so finally he goes he goes i
see you going in the bathroom
i see
i mean this went on for a few weeks i i
mean he was every day he probably gets
paid per a paper
does he come on the weekends uh i think
he took off sunday yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah so no but i mean that
just so every time you know someone
comes up to me i think it's probably you
know a guy like that trying to take my
house away you know yeah totally but
yeah so yeah no it was uh
anyhow but yeah that was uh
i just yeah it's weird when you finally
start getting a little bit of momentum
you know
yeah well you are and it's fun because i
know i did your podcast and i forgot
that it was a zoom i don't even i mean
it's been so [ __ ] i've been so cloudy
with uh
everything that went on but i wanted to
get you on here and the interesting
thing and i didn't know this is that you
go back
to high school with tom segura oh yeah
so you actually played football with tom
like on the same team yeah yeah yeah we
were uh
we were pretty good actually we were
small school
i don't know uh
tom never
tom posted a picture of him in high
school with football he covered off the
letters i think he could tell you why he
did that i don't think that's up for me
but it makes me not even want to say the
high school we played for but uh yeah we
played i was a year under tom and um i
played corner and wide receiver i was
very slow but i had good hands quick
feet you know and i was hit i was really
small i was so small like how tall were
you then bro like when i was a sophomore
i was like five three 110 pounds oh holy
[ __ ] like the jersey went past my knees
like it was wild yeah wild that and uh
dude i remember
i started on kickoff team though you
know because i had heart you know like i
was a kid
coach myers would point at me if you had
the heart of colin and i was like i
don't even think i have that much heart
but okay like like
and dude i just remember being on
kickoff team and we were playing this
team more haven
and i'm running down and the dude
fumbles the the kick and i'm like oh
i'm gonna [ __ ] be the star you know
my little [ __ ] little jew legs going
and uh and i [ __ ] get hit
i get hit by this black dude that was
like
six to probably like 240.
bro i flew four bro
more haven if you know more if you know
florida football it's glades dude well i
floated florida yeah like
like it smells like burnt sugar cane
when you get off the bus
this dude hits me i fly no [ __ ]
like five yards like like i flew off the
screen so we're watching
the video
you know the next day you know we
watched you know tafe
and my coach rewound and watched this
like literally like 25 times and each
time you know you would think people get
bored they just [ __ ]
laughing harder harder they're like holy
[ __ ] how are you i remember getting hit
how are you like i was in the air and
still going
well like i like had time to like
rationalize like hey i'm flying
like this is pretty far yeah i'm going
far
and because what they would do is on the
kickoff team they would it was smart
they like their second line would switch
side like so you never even saw it
coming
oh my god so anyways so yeah i played
football with tommy that was like my
sophomore year and he was a big guy yeah
he played defensive tackle and i think
guard or center guard or center and um
yeah i just yeah i mean yeah he had a
big ass body i was telling you he was
built like a like an old 45 year old
butcher like like just just like
he had the same exact body as he does
now if anything he's probably smaller
now oh yeah yeah he's probably the
fairies i've seen yeah yeah and uh he
got them baby little blue eye he had a
baby face with a butcher's body so it
was interesting and uh
and um yeah we were pretty close i
remember after like lunch we'd go into
the locker room and just rip on each
other like not just me yeah just me
versus him that's how we became calm no
but there would be like 40 guys sitting
around just [ __ ] god those were the
days where you would just
find out someone's insecurity and just
make fun of them in front of 30 other
guys and just
all laugh and point you know it's also
i'm sitting here thinking of myself
right now like it's i'm just trying to
it's pretty trippy if one of the guys i
played with in high school also is in
this world and doing well too like that
would that's a little that's
you don't hear that much no are there
any other people
that we have on the sidelines someone
just sent it to me he was number 69 too
of course i was seven that's why he's a
better comic than me and
did you know he tells me about um
prince fielder oh and he's like ryan in
seventh grade bro that kid's hitting
[ __ ] home runs out of
major league ballparks in the seventh
grade and then we go online and watch it
and i'm like holy bro his prince fielder
he went to your school right yeah and he
was a hell of a basketball player too
this kid was he always big but could
move like that yes yeah yeah he blows me
away too when you see somebody like
how in the [ __ ] he's a lefty he just
[ __ ] dude i remember seventh grade
yeah defense wasn't big enough for him
like he just
he was just like you think you're an
athlete until you see someone like that
remember like the first time you see it
like an athlete and you're like oh
okay yeah i should go [ __ ] like do
like origami
you know i should go like take up
knitting because i should not be on the
field with these people i felt that way
i played against rick ankiel
and baseball when i was in little league
he played for the cardinals in little
league
this [ __ ] by the way this team
was stacked they had the o'brien
brothers goddamn o'brien you know like
you know those little league teams like
like like because the coach like they
they they like finagle it so they're
just stacked and he was like he played
catcher as a lefty and he had a 12 8 or
whatever 12 3 12 8 curveball in in
little league that would drop like four
feet
you know and and you were just like oh
this is like this is a different kind of
person completely a different level yeah
yeah i mean you saw what he did i mean
you know he kind of [ __ ] the bed in the
playoffs there but then he comes back
and hits 30 home runs a year in the
league like wild but uh
yeah no and tommy tommy he was a good
ball player he was you know he he
plugged he was a plugger you know like
yeah like um but uh
yeah dude it was we had some fun times
we got pretty far i think my sophomore
year we got final eight in the state
okay and uh
that's big for florida i mean jesus
christ be you know california and
florida are the best for uh baseball and
and football for sure i feel like yeah
no doubt definitely top five i mean per
capita i think football louisiana
actually yeah is weirdly like per person
all right well i want to hear you got a
list of stories here and i love that
we're not going to go in any
chronological order so can i just pull
the top one or any one you want this
says got stabbed by a navy seal it's
hard
you know when you like
well you know
you know when you like something happens
to you and for like 10 years you don't
realize how bad it was yes yeah that was
kind of one of those so
so i guess i'll just i was a senior in
high school
and uh i was i was a virgin
you know i was a virgin prom king you
were prom king and a virgin and a
[ __ ] the saddest story ever if you're
king you got to get some [ __ ] come on
can you at least get can you dethrone
that night at least you would think can
you get your scepter wet that night at
least bro not even on prom night for
that
night for the kids
it is sad
so i'm just i wore the crown for another
three months still didn't get [ __ ] just
walking around
here she hearing
racy
whatever i was doing whatever so
so i'm a virgin i'm [ __ ] ready to get
to college because your boy needs to get
his dick wet you know like that's the
only i'm not looking at who has the best
[ __ ] business school i'm looking at
the place that will sit on your boy's
dick you know yeah so i'm all excited
i'm visiting my brother who went to
tulane
and um he was a junior at the time and
i'm all excited he's telling me about
how fun new orleans is and i'm from you
know vero beach florida there's nothing
goes on there and then you go to new
orleans and i'm like so excited i got my
favorite gap shirt you know got it that
thick brown belt where you're tucking it
into your [ __ ] little yeah fubu g
night and when we're food
i don't know i'm probably probably
probably more gap to be honest i'm not
gonna lie and um
and i'm it's the first night and i'm in
new orleans and i'm all excited i'm like
yeah i'm going to get some [ __ ] i'm
still wearing the crown you know i'm
ready
i brought it on the flight yeah yeah
that went off there and the metal
detector was a little weird but no so
i'm
so i'm with my brother and i'm sitting
there next to this dude and he's real
like ominous like feeling like he's got
a butt cut
and dark eyes like dark circles under
his eyes like he's seen people die
before you know yeah i know those
circles
so i'm just like
[ __ ] i'm so scared of this guy
because i heard he's a navy ex-navy seal
how'd you hear this
uh he had it written on his shirt no no
he uh he's one of those dudes he was in
law school at tulane and so he lived
with my brother so he was my brother's
roommate
he was like 28.
so i'm just like in awe of this guy i'm
like oh my god you're a navy seal you
know i'm just like
first hour i'm in new orleans
and uh
he's like you want to see something and
i was like yeah
i want you to yeah what do you want what
do you got especially if you're going to
whisper it like that he's like you want
to see he got real in my ear
i mean yeah i'll lower it back down but
yeah i definitely do want to see
something
he's like i don't know if i should show
you then because it seems like you're
pretty badass dude
you don't want to fight a guy that's
like i want you to go outside
yeah
you want a guy that yells at you drunk
really loud and slurs his words yeah so
i end up uh i go yeah i want to see
something and he opens up this closet
and he has guns
knives
camouflage uh and he had a bulletproof
vest he had medals in there
i called the closet of death you know
yeah yeah and he has this bulletproof
vest and i was like man you gotta prove
that that's so cool man he's like try it
on and i was like all right yeah this is
in the house where your brother also
lives my brother's in the other room
getting ready he's got an arsenal in
this [ __ ] he's putting on his food
boobs back there so
so i'm [ __ ] freaking out right
and uh are you scared like you're just
like
i'm alone with this navy seal whatever
and i put the vest on and i swear to god
it's true story and he goes
he he was playing with a knife earlier
right like this little pocket knife that
was what he would do for fun you know
and he just goes doesn't even ask me he
just goes hey it's night it's knife
proof
and uh he just [ __ ]
thrills me dog
i swear on my life drills me
and
i think i should probably call somebody
he goes he goes
i think i stabbed you
the [ __ ] they call that yeah
i go you think
you think i think you i know i think i
know
so he takes the knife out of my chest
like it was like it was quick but then
he goes i think i stabbed did i go
why do you gotta do it
[Applause]
yeah
so he stabs me right
i take the vest off
did you feel it did you feel my [ __ ]
shirt you know
that baby blue brand new
my cardigan never covered all this blood
god damn it i'm sending you a bill
my mom's not gonna be happy did you
right away feel the point did you feel
it you don't feel anything so you don't
feel i didn't feel the knife go in it
was so quick the knife was so sharp but
i want to say you say that's not that
big but that's also
after it went through a supposed
bulletproof vest yes yeah
hard enough hard enough you got that
bruce lee three-inch punch on him
i love those videos the guy's like all
right dude we're gonna work on this at
home for a while
what i'm to do is stand an inch away
just
back to his chairs and [ __ ]
so he goes like that right and so i take
the vest off and i think i'm i'm dying
like because like you said i think it's
my heart i think my heart sure is
spitting blood like a volcano yeah
like i literally think of
like like just like just blood just like
just right from the heart brother's just
over here in the other room and you've
just been saying he just put his food he
buttoned up
i go damn
and so he comes out i got blood oh it
goes over me gushing
blood on he takes my gap shirt and plugs
the win again sure god damn
thing we got a long sleeve
so he [ __ ] he's plugging it up he's
plugging it up my brother comes out my
brother's like
you're here an hour
what did you do you
like you got he's like mad at me he's
like what did you do
so i was like uh so he comes out he's
like what the [ __ ] he's like all right
get in my car he's like getting the
wrangler you know
so my brother's got this badass wrangler
that i'm bleeding to death in sick roll
bar [ __ ] you know bad ass no big tires
so you know if you want to die in any
car you got to die in a cool wrangler
you know you don't want to die at a ford
escort
[Laughter]
i'd be like stab me again
so he stabs so i'm bleeding right and uh
my brother's driving like a crazy like
going on
is the [ __ ] seal with you too
he's back there yeah in case any [ __ ]
[ __ ] goes down
the afghan fire
[Laughter]
he's calling his boys
okay okay
okay
alpha team go alpha team go i'm like
[ __ ] i'm just dude we don't need all of
y'all here
he calls out to all of them they all
like it's like that movie when they're
all like
like he's at a strip club like oh i got
a goat like uh what's that move
armageddon
so our brother's in trouble so i get to
the emergency room i think i'm going to
die right i really do like i really do
think it's my heart
and uh
and i get pain in my in my stomach for
some reason everything's going to freak
yeah yeah of course i got pain in my
stomach so i'm cramping up so bad that i
can't breathe i literally can't breathe
i'm like
like
[ __ ] dude and it was hurting so bad
[ __ ] just stomach cramps you know
worse than that hit i took sophomore
year you know it was bad you know and uh
we get to emergency room
and i got blood all over me and like you
know it's in new orleans so they're like
yeah you're yeah you're definitely give
me a band-aid
if you're not shot you get in the back
of the line if you gotta get shot with a
knife vest on then we got an old gap
shirt or something we can give this guy
[Laughter]
it's so funny that they have wardrobe
my friend's dying nah i just gotta get
me at least put them in some fresh clean
so anyway so i'm in the emergency room
i just remember this i remember the
nurse missing my missing my [ __ ] and
that's just like my brother's like what
the [ __ ] you can't even get you're like
don't curse here he's like my brother's
dying you know like it was like intense
you know i had blood all i look like
carrie from carrie you know like yeah
the original one and uh and i got blood
or whatever and she finally gets it in
like i didn't ask him what happened or
anything his homeboy over there like i
stabbed him this is the thing it gets
really good so so i so they get the iv
in they the doctor goes well we think
his lung might be collapsed so my heart
oh by the way the star-spangled banner
is why i think it's my heart but your
heart's here so your heart's good if you
want to get whatever so
uh they think my lungs collapse because
your lung goes all the way up there who
knew i didn't
um
so then i go
i'm like okay so i'm having trouble
breathing to give me a volume to relax
my stomach muscle that pain goes away
but then the pain in my chest where you
know all that [ __ ] jack chest muscle
where i bench you know 225 five times
yeah it's ripped you know and uh
and and so i start feeling that pain so
they give me demerol and then once they
gave me that demerol boy i was like oh
you're blind down here get me a
hurricane
i was just like oh boy i'll give you
some beads shown in titted boy it's a
half and a hat
i didn't give a [ __ ] that i got stabbed
i really didn't i was so [ __ ] up i was
like
just flying
and i was like we're down here in the
french quarter so anyway so then
i'm sitting there they give me the
demerol they they take the x-ray they
see that it just missed my lung like
just missed it but they got to keep me
there for six hours to make sure
like protocol or whatever
so i'm laying
i'm laying there and next thing i know
this [ __ ] new orleans cop comes in
and he's like
six to 250 black cop who's just he's
telling me it's the kid that blindsided
you in football
he gained five pounds
he never got taller
that would have been unbelievable so
so he comes in and he's walking and you
know mind you i'm from a small town i
you know and this is like a badass new
orleans cop and you could hear his feet
like hitting the floor
and right before the cop came in the
navy seal said to me i forgot to say
that he goes hey you gotta tell the cop
you stabbed yourself
i go what he goes
i don't want to get in trouble you got
to tell the cop you stop i was like
oh he's like
so and i was like well what do you want
me to say and then the complex starts
walking it like i didn't even have time
to go over a story so i stabbed himself
sealed jump right here
why do you have blood all over your
hands man yeah yeah that guy stabbed
himself so i don't i don't know what to
say i didn't take improv yet you know
301 shout out you know and
so i [ __ ] the cop goes what happened
here and i was like uh well officer i uh
i was playing with a knife and a dog
well a big dog uh jumped on me and i
stabbed myself
i swear to god cop looks at me goes
all right well enjoy new orleans have a
good day that was it that was it i swear
to god he didn't ask what kind of dog he
didn't ask like you know you're alive so
what i don't want to feel good
i got titties to yeah on bourbon street
man
he's like get this guy gap shirt and
call it a dead call today
i just think he didn't want to do it
we're going to give him a 25 gift
certificate to the gap call tonight
so
so he leaves dude and i'm like blinking
i'm like
maybe see y'all no no no i'm too scared
i'm too scared at the end of the day i'm
telling this guy's a navy seal who knows
what the [ __ ] he could do to you he'll
kill the cops
but if he even asked me if it was a
golden doodle i wouldn't even know what
kind of dog it was you know what i mean
like ask me one question
yeah he would have killed the cop
like
like people go through the roof
so anyways
my brother goes to me i'm about to get
stitched up he goes hey
so i talked to the doctor
he said he get you a scar he'll stitch
you up get a scar like a playboy bunny
i go what he goes yeah you get that
playboy bunny scarf so the doctor walks
in i'm like doc i want that playboy
bunny and he's like what
my brother plays a prank
on his brother that just got stabbed
by a navy seal his roommates
his room like i feel like my brother set
up the whole thing just to play this fun
price
the old playboy prank
he's like what the [ __ ] you talking
about all right never mind you know
whatever so he stitches me up
we leave the hospital
and i go to a concert that night and i
knew we were going to go to this well i
didn't know i was going to go after
getting stabbed but i was supposed to go
to this concert because it was my
brother's band that he managed
and we're driving back into wrangler my
brother's like hey you want to go still
see that concert the band i managed i
was like yeah dan that's what i want to
[ __ ] do after getting stabbed by your
roommate who's a navy seal so anyways we
go to the concert and uh the navy seal i
swear on my life and i already knew this
before but he's in the band
i swear to god in my life i swear and
he's on guitar and he sees me in the
crowd it's not like they had like more
than five people there yeah
and that band is hoobasting no no no
i was like no [ __ ] what i was gonna
go bigger i don't know why i wanted to
do this
lumineers or some [ __ ] so
so he gets on mic
and he's like hey man
sorry again
there's five people there he's gotta be
on the microphone to do this oh yeah
he's gonna just
go well he speaks very he could have
been down he speaks very low though you
know so he's on the mic he's like hey
man you over there 20 feet away
uh so he goes uh you go sorry about the
accident and i was like again for the
third time i don't think it's an
not an accident you stabbed me you
straight up stabbed me bro like
like
it's not an accident
can we stop stop trying to make yourself
feel good so mind you
he ends up
dedicating a song to me it's probably
come on shot to your heart or some [ __ ]
stabbed to your heart and uh
anyways so i end up
i leave there
and they only gave me like advil and
[ __ ] but anyways i went i went to a
party the next night at this paint mixer
when a paint mixer essentially is you go
to this frat house you take off all your
clothes and you throw paint all over
girls and [ __ ]
is dark yeah it's unreal
i've never heard of that one in my life
it's just a way to touch women without
asking essentially oh great yeah it's
pretty cool back then it was completely
different times
you know so anyways so i end up showing
my
my scar playboy scar yeah my playboy my
bunny to all these girls i'm taking my
shirt off hammered drunk being like i
got stabbed [ __ ] turns out women
if you get stabbed
and it's fresh conversation piece yeah
man so i went home with this gorgeous
girl
and uh we're making out and then i heard
she [ __ ] like five guys or something
so i thought she probably had aids so i
didn't go upstairs no it didn't go i
could have [ __ ] her it would have been
the best ending of this story but it's
actually funnier that i got scared of a
college girl because she's you know you
know back then when you're like oh she
had sex with three guys
what and now i'd [ __ ] a girl who like
you know [ __ ] you know half of detroit
and i was like oh she's clean
she's clean she didn't she wore a condom
she told me yeah you'll never forget a
friend of mine he told me he's like i
had sex with this girl last night and
i'm like jewelry robbery goes no i go
was she on the pill or anything i heard
she was i was like hearsay
here says the birth control method we're
going with here huh [ __ ]
here's and who are you talking to
that's giving you this invitation
[Laughter]
yeah jenny's on the pill yeah she'll
take a comment sure that she'll take to
come here yes
you heard she [ __ ]
i never look you know what blew my mind
one time i was like in my 20s unsafest
birth control method by the way hearsay
saying i was here saying yeah you heard
i heard she was on the pill
it was a game of telephone it started
with don't [ __ ] her yeah and then it
ended with i don't know and she might be
on the pavement so i [ __ ] i remember
this girl goes
i go um i [ __ ] a girl you know raw dog
or whatever and and uh
and i was like yeah but she asked if i
had condom before so you know she's
clean
and she's like maybe she asked you for a
condom to protect you from what she has
and that's when i was like oh my god
women can get like it like it always
made me think give me [ __ ] yeah like i
don't know why i just like i never
thought a woman would they're so nice
yeah right yeah yeah so anyway so
long story short or long story long for
that matter
i i go to a party i have fun the rest of
the weekend
i don't talk to him much you know
and um
a few months later i swear to god i
found out the dude was never a navy seal
i swear in my life i swear in my life
what do you mean i don't i don't i just
i might just tackle weapons and stabbing
people he was just in the gi joe and he
grew and he never grew out of it i guess
i feel like more people lie specifically
about navy seal you know what i mean why
i reached a high like why are you lying
about the highest one you got a t-shirt
that says the only easy day was
yesterday and that makes you [ __ ]
navy seal get the [ __ ] out of you yeah
i'm sure there's probably a navy seal
listening right now that wants to kill
this non-navy seal and yeah go ahead and
there's a non-navy seal who believes
he's a navy seal listen to this who
wants if you want to kill that guy
let's take a quick break and tell you
about our first sponsor liquid iv the
hot summer months are here and we need
to be proactive to keep our body fueled
up and hydrated making hydration a
priority helps us feel healthier on a
day to day basis and fuels us to our
highest potential one stick of liquid iv
and 16 ounces of water hydrates faster
and more efficiently than water alone
not only that but the product tastes
great with flavors like watermelon
strawberry and lemon lime sounds like
summer doesn't it i'm using liquid iv
every day i go out i walk i drop one in
my water before i go out in the morning
and i hit one up at night just so i can
get to bed at night hydrated hydration
is important y'all liquid iv hydrates
faster and more efficiently than water
alone it contains five essential
vitamins more vitamin c than an orange
and as much potassium as a banana
healthier than sugary sports drinks
there's no artificial flavors or
preservatives and with less sugar than
an apple it's made with clean
ingredients it's non-gmo it's vegan and
it's free of gluten dairy and soy grab
your liquid iv in bulk nationwide at
costco where you can get 25 off when you
go to liquidive.com and use code
honeydew at checkout that's 25 off of
anything you order when you get better
hydration today using promo code
honeydew at liquidive.com
our next sponsor is stamps.com are you
still going to the post office are you
still paying full price for postage well
thanks to stamps.com you don't have to
anymore you can mail and ship anytime
anywhere right from your computer you
can send letters you can ship packages
and you can pay less a lot less with
discounted rates from usps ups shout out
to ups baltimore primary one joe avenue
and more stamps.com saves businesses
thousands of hours and tons of money
every year i use stamps.com all the time
back in the day i was doing all our
merch i tell you about it all the time
man and
it was so easy to sit there boom bang
them out weigh it sticker boom off you
go you drop never had to do anything it
was super easy and stamps.com brings the
services of the us postal service and
ups right to your computer it's a
must-have for any business whether
you're a small office sending invoices a
side hustle etsy shop shipping out
orders or just navigating this hybrid
worklife stamps.com can handle it all
with these simply use your computer to
print official u.s postage 24 7 for any
letter any package any class of mail
anywhere you want to send once your mail
is ready just schedule a pick up or drop
it off it's that simple all right with
stamps.com you get discounts up to 40
off post office rates and up to 66
percent off of ups shipping rates and
not to mention stamps.com is a fraction
of the cost of those expensive postage
meters stamps.com is a no-brainer saving
you time and money it's no wonder nearly
1 million small businesses already use
stop wasting time going to the post
office and go to stamps.com instead
there's no risk and with my promo code
honeydew you get a special offer that
includes a four week trial plus free
postage and a digital scale there's no
long-term commitments or contracts just
go to stamps.com click on the microphone
at the top of the home page and type in
honeydew that's stamps.com promo code
honeydewstamps.com
never go to the post office again our
next sponsor is mint mobile after years
of fine print contracts and getting
ripped off by big wireless providers if
we've learned anything it's that there's
always a catch so when i first heard
that mint mobile offers premium wireless
service starting at just 15 bucks a
month i thought what's the catch but
after speaking with them and using their
service it all made sense there isn't
one mint mobile's secret sauce is that
they're the first company to sell
wireless service online only by cutting
out retail stores there's no crazy
overhead cost that gets passed down to
you in the form of mystery fees instead
mint just passes on sweet savings direct
to you for people looking for extra
savings mint mobile offers premium
wireless for just 15 bucks a month all
plans come with unlimited talk and text
plus high speed data delivered on the
nation's largest 5g network you can
still use your own phone with any mint
mobile plan and you can keep your same
number along with all your existing
contacts and if you're not a hundred
percent satisfied mint mobile has you
covered with their seven-day money-back
guarantee switch to mint mobile and get
premium wireless service starting at
just 15 bucks a month to get your new
wireless plan for just 15 bucks a month
and get the plan shipped to your door
for free go to mintmobile.com
honeydew that's mintmobile.com honeydew
cut your wireless bill to 15 bucks a
month at mintmobile.com
honeydew now let's get back to the do
stolen valor man dude so yeah well you
mentioned college and you just i don't
even want to say i want to hear about
this frat house story oh
you know what i'm talking about yeah
it oh so
so i end up going to tulane
that's the school you picked was it by
the way how many did you actually go
visit huh how many did you actually go i
did in florida state
but i did like a bunch of ghb and i like
was like it wasn't even fun i just like
sat in a dorm you remember ghb yeah i
remember my story about it
was it big in your high school i guess i
guess i guess i didn't learn from him uh
but yeah i
i didn't do it that much but yeah i
didn't really have that much fun and
then i only applied to like two other
schools but
um
wait kyle oh the frat house the fire
so i uh
so i end up
uh we i bought a cat with my uh
ex-girlfriend
it'd be weird if we were married now
after this story but uh so we bought a
cat together this exotic short hair cat
named bailey it was like 150 bucks which
or 250 which in college that's like nine
posters that's like yeah yeah you know i
could have got that college jim belushi
poster again or john belushi that
everyone has so anyway so we buy this
cat and i bring it to college
and
and it's supposed to stay with her in
her dorm she's a freshman it lasted
maybe three days before they're like you
can't have a [ __ ] cat in the dorm
like what are you doing
so then now it's living with me in my
frat house like you know a [ __ ] and a
frat whatever like it's just absurd to
have a like ex not just like a cat but
like an expensive exotic short hair cat
with the smushed face and
i remember people would like [ __ ] with
and he'd have his little paw like coming
under the door just like you know he was
fun you know bailey and uh
it gets towards the end of the year i
don't even know how this cat's still
alive i don't remember feeding it and uh
but
i think it probably wanted to escape or
something but you know it so
my friends at the end of the year they
ransack my room good friends whatever
and i have like
papers and [ __ ] all over the floor i
don't know whatever my room was a
[ __ ] disaster and i and i went to eat
and i took this light because they broke
my lamp i took this light this hot
like construction light and i put it on
my
ladder that goes up to my loft
i didn't clamp it i just put it there
with the cord and i left i guess i left
it on
i go to eat and what i'm thinking
happened if i had to csi this [ __ ] is
that the
c being cat
no
i think the cat not knocked the light
off that's what i'm guessing and then
what hit carpet or your picture yeah and
it just fell right down and like face
down face down the place so i come back
from dinner
it's only like 30 minutes
bro i [ __ ] you not there's a dragon in
my room
because
he's blowing fire like bro just burned
down behind me and i stood 20 feet from
it and watched it now and i know exactly
what that [ __ ] turned into bro well it
was just out my it was out my window so
i was like and i was like just my window
for the place is burning not the whole
place just
yeah there's like a dragon in my room
and uh it's like hitting the house next
door i mean it's like 30 feet out and i
look at the girl no one else was in
there
no 40 people died no no no
40.
like nah just six
that's always the rule you will go way
too high so that when you do dial back
the truth it feels all right it was 38.
it was it was 30. it was like it was
still it was 20 years
57.
we lost a lot of good men that day
so i [ __ ] so i go i go
i go to i go to the girl drive and i
swear to god i still remember it and i
see this flame i just look at her i go
keep driving like i turned into the navy
seal i was just like keep driving i ever
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
are you uh are there fire trucks and
[ __ ] pulling up yet or is this like
justification she drives a little bit
away there's like 400 people outside the
house all right and they're all in favor
of the fire because they all hated our
fraternity you know okay
and i'm yelling it was the sigma news
like i'm trying to blame it on another
frat
news
so
so i [ __ ] they put out the fire
and uh i'm sitting there i'm standing
there with the other with everyone and
no one knows it's my room except for me
you know
[ __ ] dude this was crazy so we're
standing there and the firefighter
starts walking down out the store out
the stairs and he's holding
bailey
okay
and he's like who's cat
and bailey's dead
and i'm like dude my girlfriend
face cat probably running about 250.
anybody it's like how does this guy know
so much about cats so
he goes whose goddesses and i was like
i'm not [ __ ] saying it's my cat in
front of all these people it's
embarrassing as [ __ ]
i was like everyone's gonna know i own a
cat you know that's what you did
[Laughter]
i think if you thought it was exotic
before wait till you see it
no one has this cat so
you got a lot going through your mind
your girlfriend's going to kill you bro
you don't want to [ __ ] [ __ ] up you
have no idea where my brain was at this
point in my life too i was i was a i was
not in good head space so
so i go the cat's dead by the way it
died from the smoke it didn't die from
the fire so you can still see the guy
you know and he's like who's cat is this
i was like [ __ ] dude
and it was like it was like it felt like
price is right
but it was wrong you know like come on
down like whose cat is this and i was
just like [ __ ] that's
my cat
he's not even upset all right
he goes i started god he goes what do
you want me to do with it i was like i
don't know man [ __ ] why are you
asking me that in front of all these
people can we like take it like
i'll just make sure
[Laughter]
because you want to stuff it yeah put it
on the wall yeah
he did something worse bro i swear to
god this is what happened he goes well
what do you want you want you want it
and i was like to bury it i was like and
i was like do i bury it like i'm looking
around you know when people like 500 600
i don't know what to do and i was like
nah just just throw it away
he's like hang on let me see if i can't
punt this [ __ ]
like kobe bro
incinerate it throw it back
in the trash and then someone i swear to
god someone threw a 40 on its head like
and not like in the cool way like not
like hey let's not worry about that out
for bailey let's pour it out because
he's on fire
so
that cat dies
obviously that so now i got to call my
girlfriend
i'm like uh hey
good news bad news good news
bailey's here
[Laughter]
[Music]
good news is 40 people died just kidding
just barely just bailey's dead
40 cats died really 40 cats not just
ours
the best way to break fast
because of fire how did it happen i was
like well you know cats
[Music]
so mind you
oh she yells she's not happy and then uh
this is where my mind's at i swear to
god this is what happened this is where
i was at the time you would think i'd be
like depressed
my room just
like store like scorched no one died
everyone got out of the house it was
thank god it was like six at night but
did it burn the whole place down
everywhere yeah but but the house had to
be completely yeah in a way i kind of
helped the house you know you know i was
doing a good thing you know i was
thinking so
so that night i swear to god
dude i go to [ __ ] um
[ __ ] i just drew a blank i went to a
concert
of the people that sing she's my cherry
pie lauren warren yeah and they played
at um
this like
bar for like a hundred people
and i just remembered just like
like just slam dancing with a bunch of
like bikers to warrant that night being
like my cat's dead dude
that's what you're out there celebrating
yeah i was like david cat's dead they're
like dude me too my brother's dead well
you know we had fun she's my and we sing
cherry pie i sang it on the mic he came
out
i swear to god i mean it was like a
hundred people in a bowl like he's not
killing it but
you know and i was singing cherry pie
and i i and uh you know the navy seal
guy was their guitarist i'm pretty sure
pretty sure he was
that guy i'm pretty sure they got
guitars tomorrow night
look
i know it was an accident i go no i
think you burnt the house
so mind you
me stature limitations hopefully because
i started getting some letters in the
mail and your boy just ignored those
so
there are some folks if you want summons
you can go [ __ ] yourself subpoena with a
p i'll see you there it might have been
a p yeah
so yeah so i probably won't go back to
new orleans for a while no i did i
wouldn't
tell me about the overdose you actually
is this you yeah you you had an overdose
a mild
i mean any overdose is not mild yeah it
was an underdose
[Laughter]
i don't even know where to start with
this one i was just um
it was in new orleans
but i graduated college right long story
short again i i moved to la right after
college to be a producer
i thought i was going to be a producer
because i read one book on producing i i
got a job as a pa
and uh for one weekend i drove cross
country i thought i had a full-time job
it was one weekend i wore like a suit
the first day i had no idea what i was
doing
they're like yeah no you gotta try to
get a job every week i was like i'm done
being a producer you know so anyways
mind you
i i'm living in l.a i visit my new
orleans with my buddies
and uh
at this point like i didn't really have
a job i was in really good shape though
like most jacked i've ever been you know
and
and i never did cocaine that much i
really didn't i've never bought cocaine
you know i i've done it i never did it
that much
[Laughter]
i never did it on tuesdays
tuesday was my day tuesdays
thursday mornings i never did cocaine
tuesday at two
so
i do uh
i go out we're doing like benders we got
a hotel room down there in the quarter
and uh
this
my buddy was dating a stripper
she was so hot oh my gosh she was so hot
and we all go out and i start doing some
bumps you know
and uh next thing i know i'm with his
stripper girlfriend but not like
thinking i'm gonna [ __ ] her but like
that's how coked up i was i was just
talking to a stripper about life you
know overlooking lake pontchartrain like
we were sitting in her car just like
being like what do you think about the
big meaning of life and she's like you
know like are you gonna try to [ __ ] me
or you want to keep talking so anyways i
do so much coke until like eight in the
morning
and uh
and i was like all right she's like i'll
drive you back i was like all right cool
and i get back and i don't know how much
cocaine you've done but like i have
insane anxiety disorder so when you
start coming down from that [ __ ] it's
it's the worst feeling in the world and
um like what for you what happens
guilt and you feel like [ __ ] about
yourself clearly i think i'm dying like
it goes through there physically you
feel really dying yeah yeah physically
like i i've had a lot of panic attacks
in my life after that you know like i've
never whatever i wasn't diagnosed with
anxiety disorder back then but
i'm freaking the [ __ ] out i think i'm
gonna die from like just because i can't
even like walk i'm so exhausted you know
so
i'm with my buddies and they're like you
know what you should do a gravity bong
hit to relax
and i was like i've never been good with
weed but for some reason
my brain i'm so dumb at the time i'm
like yeah that will help yeah i'll do a
gravity bong hit
so i do a gravity bong hit and i go
completely numb and like paralyzed like
i can't
move my arm like i'm on the couch i'm
stuck and i'm completely numb
and i'm like i literally like i'm
looking at my arm and i go you know move
arm it's like sleep paralysis but i was
wide awake
and i was like going back and forth to
the room and i'm like i'm freaking out
i'm gonna die so i don't know how much
of it is from the coke from stop doing
the coke to
to the weed
and i go to my buddy i was like dude you
gotta drive me to the er where you know
where i got stuff
so i go um
i go you know you gotta take me he's
like stop being a [ __ ] you know when
your friends like don't be a little
[ __ ] just [ __ ] man up you know i was
like i'm trying but i'm [ __ ] can't
move my [ __ ] arms bro i can't move
and finally i was like yo just [ __ ]
drive me to the er dude i gotta go to
the yard i see i'm having a heart attack
because my heart is packed like
so he takes me into the er he doesn't
even come in with me that's like the
kind of friend y'all
would do i'm not stopping the car yeah
my brother get out yeah i'm just gonna
roll like if it's a red light i'll i'll
stop so he's like he pulls around he's
just like all right see you later i'm
like all right and i walk in i'm just
like hey and at this point like i've
convinced myself i'm having a heart
attack so i'm just like i go up to the
later it's like i think i'm having a
heart attack
and she's like um
she's like all right she's like she let
me actually
skip the line i guess i sold it well
enough and suddenly they bring me back
they do an ekg
all that [ __ ]
i told him i did cocaine whatever
and uh but i was jacked then you know i
was ripped you know i look good you know
i can't
it's so funny to like think like just
because you're in shape if it's like
like you can't die like if you have yeah
yeah yeah
so i can't i'm like numb and they're
putting blood thinner in my stomach like
shooting me up with shots it hurt like a
[ __ ] and they're just putting blood
thinner in me
and then they look at my ekg and they're
like you had a heart murmur and then
somehow
right into the show i still i've never
really looked into this but they like
looked into my pat like they could see
that i've had this before so i had a
murmur so they put me in a heart ward
for three days
damn really yeah and i ran up like a 7
500 bill and that was my last time you
did cocaine
ish
that's an expensive night out bro so
then i end up
three days in heart ward and um they're
like yeah you don't [ __ ] do this [ __ ]
anymore blah blah blah so cocaine could
kill you because of the heart murmur i
don't know is this also when you found
out you had a heart murmur yeah and i've
never really looked into it since then
you know i'm figuring you know i got a
good ticker yeah yeah yeah probably not
to look into that so i end up going back
to florida and then i went flew with my
brother to la got my car and that was
the last that was when i left la for the
first time you know okay or was the last
time and uh yeah that was wild i mean
the depression after having even like
kind of an overdose you know it it'll
hit you and then that's when i got into
real estate after that like that's when
you know i stopped being a producer
stop being a producer so you drove
across the country for thinking you had
a job and they were like all right gig's
over after a couple days like literally
it was a waffle house commercial or ihop
with joel mchale
like a year later or a year ago and i
was like do you remember he's like i
remember that commercial it's like you
remember me in a
suit the pa that wore the carrying boxes
sweating getting your coffee the guy
with the suit and the dolly yeah the guy
with the briefcase
um tell me about this penis pump i want
to hear about this penis man so
i've never used one
so
so i'm mind you i got stabbed when i was
visiting tulane i love this this is like
a quentin tarantino movie we keep going
back and forth and um
and i miss i'm a senior in high school
still a virgin remember virgin prom king
and i get stabbed i still decide to go
to tulane i'm like look it can only go
uphill from here you know
and uh
i was like i'll go to college i'll
reinvent myself who knows maybe i'll
like become like a salsa king no no
salsa yeah no i do salsa and whatever
anyway so i go and it's like
before i went to lane i visited some
friends in boston college and my buddy
played football for boston college and
he had these all these
big ass football like dude like the guy
named hovann who played for the vikings
remember him
yeah and like
and like three other dudes like huge
[ __ ] like the biggest guys
you've ever seen and they all are
talking about penis pumps how they all
have them
and i'm like what like big guys like you
pumpy they're like yeah it's like bench
press before your dick you know like
they were like yeah it's just like
lifting and i was like
they sold it you know and i was like i
gotta get me one of these you know
and uh
so i get back to florida and i'm like i
gotta find out like there's no real i
don't even know if there's like google
then to like type in where to get a dick
pump there's like one place in like four
like towns to get a dick plump and it's
called southern exposure which is pretty
funny
but it was on us-1 so i went in there
like in a trench coat and sunglasses was
like i didn't want to you don't want it
i mean nowadays i'd walk in like with
flare guns yeah i don't give a [ __ ]
where are your dick pops
it's for me yeah
it's for my tiny dick yeah no my dick's
small
yeah yeah it's not big back then i'm
like walk going through a window in the
back
and then i remember i went in and i
bought the penis pump
and i and uh and i bought magnums i
bought magnums to cover so i go oh the
magnums are for my big dick getting this
penis pump for this little
for my buddy
for my buddy's little dick and the guy
with like
like gage earrings looking at me like i
don't give a [ __ ] just by the pump you
[ __ ] like why are you telling me you
just like lie you know i'm sure you've
seen that before
so
sure so i used to pump like once
before i went so what is it does it make
you hard
it make yeah like so when you're getting
yeah yeah like did you put your you put
all thick in it you could put like your
m your like halfway hard [ __ ] a little
bit of a little bit of chub you want
some chub in there and then what you
pump it yeah you pump it like what does
it say like fill it with blood yeah so
it sucks your dick so much that more
blood goes into the capillaries to make
your dick thicker okay the thing is you
got to clamp that [ __ ]
to keep the blood in there you got to
clamp your dick yeah i never i didn't
buy i never put the clamp on i didn't
real i thought you just pumped it and
then it was good like
no it goes out like a tire like
it's gonna blow i say what makes it look
like as like as a burglar was strangling
me
and then
like real hard the vein in my head and
then he just let's go is your dick
wearing a bandana
yeah it's a it's it's it's too talking
it's too bogging so so i have to make my
head bigger like it did it gave me some
girth like i needed some girth i needed
some weight
so i was like all right i'll bring it to
college so i packed this thing like i
packed my proactive my new capture and
my [ __ ] penis
and i
fly with this thing like i travel with
this thing you know and i get to my dorm
room
and i hide the pump because you don't
want it you know it's
and i hide it like like narnia like you
you can't find this yeah like you might
not remember where it is yeah
i have like instructions
like go when you get to the door go left
and then yes i [ __ ]
anyway so i used the thing one time
maybe twice
you know it doesn't and uh i believe it
was once and to have sex or just to have
some just pleasure just try it out you
know
that's where the clown
please tell me you put the crown on
obviously i'm wearing the crowd i mean
dude so
it's such a [ __ ] weird thing to have
a pump too it's like what am i going to
do like hook up with a girl and be like
let me pop it was like what are you what
are you doing why the hell do i even
have it now i just take viagra it's
great it's [ __ ] awesome so anyway so
i pump my dick but i pump it like right
before class so i just like i'm kind of
scrambling so i don't put it in my
secret spot i just put it in the drawer
and i'm just like all right whatever you
know i'll get to it you know whatever
and so you know after you jerk off you
don't know what you're thinking you know
so i just put the dick pump in there
and i go to class this is like the
second or third week and fireman walks
out like who's dick puff is this
and whose cat is
[Applause]
they're both yours
[Music]
40 dig pumps died that day 40 dig pumps
dad so
we got a dick pump at a dead cat who's
it he's i've never connected these
stories but when you hear what happens
when people come together again
i'm looking for two people right now
one for the dick pop birthday cat man
he's like
she's
ambidextrous
he's pitching with one hand on one arm
throwing it on the other
side
no it's great oh my god so so he ends up
so i go to class dude again i [ __ ] do
a gravity bomb hit before i get back so
what happened though is my buddy was
looking for a lighter to light up a
cigarette
he can't find when he goes to my side of
the room goes in the drawer and finds
this pump with like lotion in it it's
like he doesn't even know what it is so
he calls my other buddy this is b thank
[ __ ] god there was no youtube yeah
yeah thank [ __ ] i would be dead i'd
kill myself i felt if i if this happened
i swear to god it could have went viral
i would have probably killed myself
anyways so
let's try to make this clip go viral
guys go ahead yeah so
go ahead tell us the details
you know what
and then nothing happened
and that was it
anyway that's a pretty cool story uh no
so i [ __ ] my buddy aaron he calls my
buddy aaron he calls a buddy next thing
you know
he calls a girl he calls a girl they
call every gorgeous girl in my freshman
class at tulane oh no
i [ __ ] i'm on i'm doing gravity bong
hits having a good time you know and i
walk back
and
i remember i still remember it i'm like
i see like 30 people in my little ass
dorm room and oh 30. bro like that might
be a little but like honestly like
probably like 15 probably 15 and it's i
mean it's it's it's probably 90 10 girl
to guys like the hottest girls that you
pick out in the book you know the
facebook before facebook you're like oh
i'd [ __ ] her i [ __ ] her i'd [ __ ] her she
wouldn't [ __ ] me you know whatever yeah
they're all in my room and i think it's
a party
you know because i'm high as [ __ ] i'm
just like oh [ __ ] freshman party my
friend hooked it up [ __ ] yeah dude i
should have grabbed the twelver before i
got here so i come in i'm like yeah
and my buddy like the firemen i swear to
god reaches in the drawer and i swear to
god it was like he just starts waving
that [ __ ] like like a helic like a
north carolina helicopter just like it
was kitty hawk [ __ ] we're down
to kitty uh north carolina
so
does anyone know what the [ __ ] it is yet
though no one knows what it is all these
people they're kind of like they're yes
and sure
so so it's a new gravity but they they
yeah yeah yeah so they go uh
so everyone's laughing at me they're
pointing at me like
oh like what is this and i just i swear
to god i just look just like the navy
seal and i just go
that's my penis pump like that cool i
swear in my life
because i was so high if i wasn't that
high i would be like that's my dick pump
that's my i said it like i have like
four i got a whole jacket full like i
took it i remember i threw it i go
my dick pump and it broke and i was like
i kind of remember being upset about
that inside
everyone leaves they waited like two
hours to do this
i start coming down from being high i'm
like oh
my whole college career is over i'm the
little dick guy with a penis pump every
hot girl but a penis pump doesn't mean
necessarily have a little dick though
right it means you probably need
assistance getting whatever you have up
is what i'm guessing that would be a
great way to spin in and i wish you were
my friend back then
but no guy with a monster [ __ ] is like
yo i need to go to southern exposure and
drive 45
[Music]
coat and minutes
because my big dick needs to get even
bigger
so yeah so anyways so i didn't leave my
dorm room for a good two weeks i tried
to make up a lie that i was trying to
prank my friend i was like oh no i'm
buying a prank yeah okay like no one
believed me you know because i said it
so confidently and i just remember i
didn't leave my dorm for like two weeks
i was just looking out the window like
what are all the normal dicks doing you
know like it was sad
that was sad boy that was
how'd you recover from that i haven't
that's why i'm doing stan that's why i'm
here today
i'm telling you
um let's hear about losing all your
money oh man so after i had the heart of
the mild overdose i went back to florida
i got into florida real estate during
the boom i got my floor to stay licensed
past the second time but you know who's
counting um
so my mom my i got family that does a
lot of real estate in chicago
and uh
and so she's like you should do real
estate whatever like do something i was
like you know i'm so depressed you know
and i get my real estate license like
within like six months and then i'm
trying to sell like homes and [ __ ] like
i don't even know what a foyer is or
whatever i'm just saying that's how i
grew up calling it a foyer yeah yeah
never a four year yeah yeah yeah i mean
where's the argo and so
so i
i don't know what i'm doing i'm 22
you know i'm still you know i have this
heart murmur
so i don't i don't know what i'm doing
so my buddy rusty
rusty iii mind you in florida in vero
beach florida he told me that we should
do commercial real estate instead
and we should team up together
mind you rusty the third
uh was the same guy that i would be
partying with like he's an animal
good guy but in like old florida like 50
cousins all within vero beach like old
florida
so i went up to vera where i went to
high school with tom and we ended up
we did one deal where we put together 60
acres of orange groves okay
uh for like 7.8 million dollars right we
called like rusty did this all he had
like he called like four different
owners and put together
because home sales were crazy like home
builders were like going nuts for this
property
we found a home builder to buy it
we you know we were gonna make like 300
250 grand whatever one of the buyers
gets cancer and he's like terminal so
they back out of the deal i tell
my uncle i'm like yo
you got to buy this because he's big in
real estate in chicago so he he buys it
next thing i know i go from
you know having 800 dollars in my bank
account living at home to like 280 000
damn like that like that like 23 years
old
that's the thing i mean that's all the
money like in in the world
and so i went out i bought a tundra with
some [ __ ] some please put some 20s on
there i have clothes man nah dude i went
to abercrombie
stepped it up went down you got it
i got a tundra black tundra
uh with with some 20 maybe 22s not
spinners i i thought about getting
spinners um
uh
i then i you know bought the truck you
know i mean my other you know we would
go out every night we'd go down to fort
lauderdale go to this place automatic
slims would get a table rusty would take
his shirt off he decided to shave his
head into a mohawk
like [ __ ] just living the life i woke
up one night with or one morning with a
girl putting a hooters outfit on you
know like just like
going to costa rica like just [ __ ]
trying to get rid of this money as fast
as possible
because millions yeah cause we had more
money coming in i had another million
dollar like we were to resell that
property so we had that property under
contract the next day pretty much for 16
million damn so my uncle i was the king
and uh and then with like lennar angle
homes whatever and uh they end up so the
market is kind of like there's rumbling
you know about like oh you know i think
things are falling apart and then
sure enough we're waiting to get
entitlements and entitlements
essentially is what you get so you can
eventually like
build on this land so we're we need to
get those to then sell it to them
because that's how they're buying it
because they would have paid like 11
million without the entitlements and my
uncle would have been good but
sure enough they
they waited uh
we were waiting for the entitlements
market starts getting worse and worse
they back out another dude ziggy wilf
the owner of the vikings oh yeah comes
down on a private jet
and me and rusty the third meet him at
the [ __ ]
private airport he's got glasses on a
viking polo
we uh we sit down for a meeting me rusty
the third and my uncle and we get it
under contract for like 13.1 million so
we're like we're still golden
how much 13.1 and it's under contract or
we sold it for seven eight so we're
gonna still make another you know 300
g's or whatever
mind you uh so so so we're still waiting
to get the entitlements and then they're
slowly lowering the price they're like
no we don't want to pay this much and
then eventually they just walk
and we had another property under
contract where we would have made like
it was wild then right market crashed i
spent all my money you did i bought a
condo that was to lose it huh you didn't
lose it you spent it
a tomato tomato
tomato tomato
tomato so you bought a condom i bought
that condom is that not a good
investment 220.
six months later it's worth
sixty thousand dollars
no swear my life and that's the one i
stopped paying money on it crashed where
the guy down you say 220 000 and it
dropped how many months later 60 000 in
like 70 000.
yeah 60 000. now they're back to like
190 actually
you wouldn't have your money back holy
[ __ ] and that's the house i stopped
paying the mortgage on where the guys
where i kept getting the shower right
yeah so cleanest you've ever been so
clean i actually didn't even turn i
turned the shower on i wouldn't go in
but i felt like if it was on it would be
a better story in court i'm i was
[ __ ] crazy so anyways so yeah so i
went through all that money i lost the
house
um i owed the government money
uh i only paid half my taxes because i
thought i had all this other other money
coming in next thing i know i owe the
government a [ __ ] ton of money damn and
i'm not making it anymore
uh
i was so depressed boy for like a year i
like just laid in my bed and like would
just watch youtube like rolling stone
video like just like going through
youtube holes with the blinds down
just depressed as [ __ ]
and that's like
like kind of how i figured out like so
it's a long story but i ended up like
moving to new york one time that didn't
go well that's a whole nother like 45
minutes but then i went back to florida
and like i was just like trying to make
that money back like that was like every
job i was trying to take i was just
trying to
to to get and like through nepotis like
through like family stuff not doing
anything on my own and that's when i got
into stand-up when i was finally like
all right i'm done chasing this [ __ ]
money that i will never
get to and in a way stand-up was a way
for me to like
do something that like gave me kind of a
scapegoat to never reach that money so
it stopped being about the money you
know
and i took a stand-up class because
and and then like i moved to new york i
was [ __ ] working in grilled cheese
like like working a grilled cheese
restaurant yeah i was sleeping on
couches and like
did dog walk for six years
still in debt but com like just chasing
doing open mics you know 15 a week
whatever and then i met nikki and then
like literally within the last and so i
met nikki she took a picture of me
walking a dog
with wheels and she put it on instagram
and that's how you guys met and my
friend was like yo that's a comic and i
went i met her and i remember like i was
so nervous meeting her because like i i
was almost done with comment it was like
six seven years of just walking dogs
like i was running some shows but there
was nothing there was no traction i'm
not that yeah i started at 30.
and uh i met her and i remember just
like i'll really open up to people right
away i told her i got an aids test when
i was still a virgin because i fingered
a girl and i bite my nails
and that's what soul did she'll say to
this day she goes that's the day that
line right there is why you're like with
me right now
so she hires me for a dog walker i'm a
dog walker oh you are all right well i
was two times a day and then she let me
host for a caroline's
and i [ __ ] cr i was ready you know
like seven years like ready to go or and
uh
then then she's like oh come on my radio
show next thing you know like
i'm doing that i'm going on the road
with her
we're doing [ __ ] i crush doing that
doing the features
now i'm like
now i'm here i just went to mtv awards
last night i paid
almost all my debt off with comedy money
[ __ ] yeah two weeks ago like i literally
grasped yeah so it was very good god
damn that feel good yeah and like comedy
money with comedy money yeah
and coke i sell coke well that's all
right yeah i don't do it though i never
bought it no yeah yeah yeah no but yeah
dude it was [ __ ] dope dude it's like
it's been it's been like i'm finally
finding like a groove yeah you know i
haven't drank for like three years
that's good
you know i don't know i mean that kind
of stuff you know going to therapy all
that [ __ ] you know like i just didn't
realize what my all those like things
stem from like a lot of it from anxiety
disorder and like
not being able to focus and not being
able to you know
not to try to bring down the mood but i
just think that that you did though it's
okay
um listen thank you for being on here
but before we go i told you at the
beginning we started recording i'm going
to ask you so i want to hear some advice
now after everything we've talked about
yeah i want to hear some advice you
would give your 16 year old self i would
say buy the clamp for the penis pump
because the blood is gonna
you're gonna have to hold on to this
clamp for a while but
i'm trying to think what i really would
do i i honestly think i would just like
hmm god that's tough man
because it's like
i wish i i knew how to ask for help
earlier
and not think of it as a weakness yup
because a lot of people are afraid to
ask for help because it's looked at as
especially as a guy because he's like no
[ __ ] man up and take care of it on
your own [ __ ] like i never made a
dollar with any help you know it's like
nah dude yeah you did people bought your
[ __ ] yeah and helped you with that
dollar yeah yeah yeah yeah
so that's right like 16 year old self
it's okay to ask for help and if you're
not going to get it from your parents
get it from your parents or your
friend's parents or or talk to anyone
you know and don't be afraid to do that
because i think if i asked for help back
then i would have known kind of what my
disorder like my anxiety disorder was
and i would have nipped it in the bud
earlier on but then i also wouldn't be
here so maybe don't ask for help all
right and get a stab proof vests and get
a stab proof vest
dude thank you so much for being on here
plug whatever you want again yeah just
uh i'm co-host of nikki glader's podcast
um and then my podcast is called puddles
with andrew collins ryan you were on it
yeah fantastic freaking i really did
enjoy it and uh yeah and in july we're
gonna be on tour so come on out and
enjoy [ __ ] live stand-up comedy again
yeah all right well thank you again for
being on uh as always ryan sickler.com
ryan cycle on all social media we'll
talk to you all next week
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you